what we have here is a diagram of a food
web that shows us how matter and energy
are transferred between organisms in an
ecosystem but it's a little bit abstract
they don't tell us what these organisms
are they just say organism 1 organism 2
orgasm 3 and so forth
but even this gives us some information
about which organisms are the producers
the primary consumers the secondary
consumers and the decomposers
so the first thing i want you to think
about are is which arrows show us going
from producers
i'll write it that like that to primary
consumers
pause the video and think about that
which arrows show producers to primary
consumers
all right now in a food web the giveaway
that something is a producer
is that it doesn't have arrows coming
into it it only has arrows coming out of
it and so
organism one is a producer
organism five is also
a producer where are they getting their
matter and energy from well they're
getting their matter from the
environment and the energy in most cases
is coming from the sun
and the things that eat the producers
those are primary consumers so this is
an arrow that goes from a producer to a
primary consumer this is an arrow that
goes from a producer to a primary
consumer and this is an arrow that goes
from a producer to a primary consumer
now that out of the way
which arrows show us going from a
primary
consumer
to a
secondary
consumer
pause the video and think about that
well i just said that these things that
are consuming the producers these are
primary i'll say p for primary primary
consumer this is a primary consumer
this is a primary consumer as well now
secondary consumers are by definition
things that aren't decomposers but
they're eating primary consumers so
they're going to have arrows coming in
from primary consumers and out to either
other secondary consumers or to
decomposers so organism three right over
here is a secondary consumer so we're
going from a primary consumer to a
secondary consumer so this arrow is from
a primary consumer to a secondary
consumer
this arrow over here is interesting it's
a secondary consumer being consumed but
you can see that organism4 only has
arrows going into it which is a pretty
good clue that this is a decomposer so
i'm not going to call organism4 a
secondary
secondary consumer so let's keep going
what about the arrow that goes from
organism six to organism seven that
looks like primary consumer to primary
consumer well it turns out that
something can be both a primary consumer
and a secondary consumer so this is also
a secondary consumer why because it's
eating a primary consumer and it's not a
decomposer so this is also another
example of an arrow from a primary
consumer to a secondary consumer
last but not least what are the arrows
that go from a consumer
that go from a consumer to a decomposer
and we already broke this down a little
bit no pun intended
pause the video and try to think about
that
well this is the this is the only
decomposer that's depicted in this
diagram and so this is going from a
consumer to a decomposer right over here
this is going from a consumer to a
decomposer and that's all we have here
and to be clear you don't have to go
from only from a consumer to decomposer
you could have gone from a producer
straight to a decomposer you could have
arrows that look like that as well
because if a plant dies and it gets
decomposed well it's going to be that
matter and energy is going to be used by
that decomposer